c'est une accalmie qui n'est pas passée
inaperçue auprès des chercheurs et des
spécialistes du terrorisme depuis le
début de la crise sanitaire les pays
occidentaux sont moins ciblés par les
attaques et la raison de cet
affaiblissement seraient imputables
coronavirus en témoignent les zones sont
confits ou des mesures liées à la lutte
contre le coc vie 19 ont été mises en
place couvre-feu fermeture des
frontières aériennes terrestres ou
maritimes confinement ou encore
quarantaine depuis le début de l'année
on observe des disparités régionales
contrastée dans la trajectoire des
menaces dans les zones de conflit
la menace est accrue comme en témoigne
le regroupement et l'intensification de
l'activité de l'état islamique d'irak et
du levant en irak et en syrie ainsi
qu'au sein de certaines de ses filiales
régionales
cependant dans les zones sans conflit la
menace semble avoir diminué à court
terme les mesures visant à minimiser la
propagation du coc u19 tels que le
confinement les restrictions de
mouvements semblent avoir réduit le
risque d'attaqués terroristes dans de
nombreux pays
mais le haut fonctionnaire onusien
tempère son analyse notamment au sujet
des activités de recrutement et de
financement qui reste difficile à cerner
si l'europe est le continent américain
semble être épargné dans les zones où
les terroristes sont légion l'activité
ne semble pas ralentir le 9 août dernier
à 70 km de la capitale nigérienne cet
humanitaire dont six français et un
guide nigériens sont retrouvés
assassinés le niger est en proie depuis
2010 à des attaques djihadistes opérés
par des milices de boko haram au sahel
plus largement de nombreux français sont
pris pour cible j'ai décidé de renforcer
les mesures de sécurité pour nos
ressortissants dans la région
nous poursuivons l'action pour éradiquer
les groupes terroristes
avec l'appui renforcé de nos partenaires
mais en pleine pandémie
la véritable menace semble venir
d'internet la pandémie augmente le
risque potentiel de cybercriminalité par
les terroristes pour lever et déplacé
des fonds autre crainte celle d'une
menace terroriste de l'intérieur
autrement dit qui proviendraient de
groupuscules déjà présents sur le sol
européen les prisons et les centres de
détention parfois berceau de la
radicalisation sont donc surveillés de
très près d inquiétude aiguë persistent
concernant la radicalisation et l'échec
de la réhabilitation dans les prisons
et la libération imminente de détenus
dangereux ayant des antécédents ou des
liens avec le terrorisme
malgré l'accalmie apparent dans les
zones sans conflit le bureau de lutte
contre le terrorisme des nations unies a
mis en place un système de multi agences
pour fournir un soutien aux états
membres qui en font la demande
notamment ceux qui doivent faire face au
retour de leurs ressortissants dialyse
et de leurs familles protection
rapatriement poursuite réadaptation
encore réintégration nous avons
contribué à donner la priorité à notre
travail sur les victimes du terrorisme
malgré l'arrestation de plusieurs de ses
figures de la perte de certains des
territoires qu'elle avait gagné et des
conséquences de la pandémie due
coronavirus d'âge semble-t-il n'a
toujours pas perdu sa capacité de
nuisance